vanellope what did you think of your
fellow princesses new books the
transformations of 2d Disney Princesses
into the 3d space of Ralph breaks
against her net we're pretty striking
but some of them were also a bit freaky
he must have panicked when Cinderella
came at you with that smashed glass
slipper and that mean expression on her
face I was not the cinders we know and
love but props you for introducing the
ladies to the comfort of casual clothes
we've got plenty to say about those
outfits too in wreck-it Ralph to some of
the new Disney Princesses looks paid off
big-time
but others missed the mark keep watching
to the end to discover which princess we
think looks almost exactly the same Snow
White better the first three Disney
Princesses must have posed the biggest
challenge to the animators but with Snow
White's they got it just right they kept
her signature look for her face hair and
clothes but perhaps more importantly
they kept her joyful spirit remember
Snow White was only 14 in her film and
that youthful excitement shines through
and wreck-it Ralph - Cinderella worse
when it comes to the new version of
Cinderella however we aren't quite so
impressed and it's partly down to her
hair her bangs and bun are just too much
the bangs are even more apparent when
Cinderella changes into casual clothes
and wears her hair in a low ponytail
plus her facial expression when she
pulls her smashed glass slipper out just
doesn't feel right
Aurora better while the hair change
didn't get a thumbs up for Cinderella we
have to say we like the quirky new zoo
on Aurora that curled front section is
giving us life and her 1950s inspired
victory rolls are totally in keeping
with the era her movie was released in
we love her casual outfit and grace -
Jasmine worse wow we like the addition
of the gold trim on Jasmine's outfit
we're not totally sold on the new
version of her face it looks like the
animators were a little heavy-handed
with the amount of eyeliner they added
and we can't help but think that she was
a little shortchanged with her casual
outfit - Ariel better Ariel undergoes
arguably the best transformation from 2d
to 3d
everything about her appearance in Ralph
Rick's Internet is more glowing and
sparkly her red hair shines her gown
glistens her jewelry gleams she's owning
her new look Belle better on the subject
of sparkles Belle's
outfit has also been given a glimmering
upgrade her iconic yellow gown now
glistens like gold and her casual outfit
is truly amazing
we just love that BFF slogan beside of
the silhouette Pocahontas worse
there's something about Pocahontas new
look that feels a bit off some fans have
pointed out her jawline as the main flaw
in this new version it was also a shame
that the beautiful shape of the original
Pocahontas eyes weren't carried across
[Music]
new lines worse just like there's
something not quite right about
Pocahontas is jawline through lunch chin
and jaw seem a little strange in Ralph
Rick's the Internet the animators also
didn't really add anything extra to her
outfit we would have loved to see some
more glitz and glamour like we did with
Ariel and Belle Tiana
better
Tiana's the first princess from the
Disney Revival era but that doesn't mean
she hasn't undergone changes in
wreckit-ralph - although we aren't
totally sold on her new princess look we
are living for her relaxed hair in the
casual clothes segments of the movie and
when she brings Ralph back for the frogs
kiss
Rapunzel better as tango came out in
2010 Rapunzel's original look is already
3d so there isn't much difference so
we'll focus on her outfit instead in the
comfy clothes section of Ralph breaks
the Internet Rapunzel's purple color
scheme is perfectly translated into
casual wear we just love those gold
stars on her leggings Merida better the
animators really succeeded in making
their princesses new styles like
heightened versions of the original and
that's exactly what they did with Merida
we didn't think her hair could give any
more curly or wild than it already was
but dizzy proved us wrong in wreck-it
Ralph - it's not just her look either
her silkiness was also exaggerated and
her Scottish accent - give me a moose
nail Lea's gonna react to adapt in his
eye Elsa worse there's something very
specific about Elsa's new look and Ralph
breaks the internet that we aren't
loving and that's her exaggerated
eyelids we don't see her purple
eyeshadow in frozen but that area feels
too prominent in this new version her
lipstick is also darker which doesn't
quite fit anna better anna on the other
hand looks better like elsa this new
version looks very similar to the
original but the subtle differences are
positive her hair has more of an auburn
glow her casual outfit really nails her
relaxed personality and her expressive
face is working in full force especially
when she first meets vanilla p Moana the
same our final entry is Disney's most
recent princess so it's not surprising
that Mona's animation style is the most
similar to Ralph breaks the internet
after all mallanna's movie only came out
two years earlier and that's why it also
makes sense that there isn't much
difference between the original Moana
and this new version her outfits her
face her hair they're all essentially
the same which wreck-it Ralph to Disney
Princess transformation is your favorite
be sure to tell us in the comments rekka
draft to Disney Princesses who looked
better and who looked worse and that's a
wrap
subscribe to the things and don't forget
to give this video a big thumbs up we'll
catch you next time thanks for watching